bom dia
vou tentar que falar para vocês o que eu
acho que nem eu acredito não acho
acredito que que me levou estar aqui
nessa manhã
palestrando pra vocês no td ex que é de
suma importância no mundo todo
numa noite de fevereiro de 2014 no país
peru numa cidade pequena num jogo de
futebol onde eu jogava pelo cruzeiro
pela taça libertadores
ao entrar em campo no segundo tempo
toda vez que a bola vinha em minha
direção onde pegava na bola ouvia o som
e de macaco enfim isso foi aumentando a
cada minuto dentro do jogo e como não
estava esperando estávamos perdendo o
jogo na frente fica ligado na atenção do
da partida por ser uma partida
importante
nem me toquei no que estava acontecendo
o tempo que é uma coisa que não era a
primeira vez que tinha acontecido a
gente vai se acostumando e vai vai
superando tudo isso
ao término do jogo faltava ter um pouco
tempo acabou o jogo eu estava na linha
do lado do do campo quando terminou a
partida já estava toda a imprensa na
beira do campo ea imprensa vem em minha
direção eu imaginando que ele falaria do
do resultado quem tinha perdido o jogo
na minha cabeça já estava com a sua
resposta pronta porque as perguntas no
futebol normalmente são sempre as mesmas
é então as respostas também são as
mesmas
então já estava com ela pronta eu ficava
fica fácil né então imaginei que
perguntar perguntar ia como porque
perdeu porque não fez o gol porque então
já tinha aquelas mesmas resposta pronta
e pra minha surpresa isso tinha
de 3 a 5 segundos que tinha acabado o
jogo foi muito rápido
a pergunta foi diferente de todas que eu
tinha escutado alterámos um jogo
a pergunta foi a seguinte ele me
perguntaram o que eu sentia o que o como
eu me sentia depois de ter conquistado
tantos títulos jogado em tantos países
está sofrendo aquele ato de racismo em
jura não lembro muito bem como ele falou
mas num país vizinho nós e aquilo me
surpreendeu porque como falei imaginava
a mesma pergunta e aquilo me surpreendeu
eu fiquei meio sem sem a resposta eu
peguei o gancho dele simplesmente como
eu não tinha a resposta é pegar o gancho
da parte que ele falou de conquistas e e
de títulos que tinha vencido na minha
carreira que eu falei simplesmente que
trocaria todo todos os meus títulos pela
igualdade racial social enfim foi que eu
que eu falei mas foi muito rápido e
alterno foi o vestiário tomei um banho
não pegava o celular no estádio é uma
cidade muito precária no hotel também
pegava muito pouco
cheguei no hotel anjo já era tarde aqui
no brasil uma hora peguei o telefone
como de praxe e cheguei pra casa
quando liguei pra casa minha família
minha esposa meus filhos todo mundo
perguntando o que tinha acontecido como
eu tava eu falei em tom normal perder o
jogo né
chateado mas faz parte do esporte e se
ganha se e perde achando que era isso
que estava perguntando a família não a
si isso que aconteceu eu não estava
sabendo de nada
como não tinha internet nada lá no
quarto era muito ruim ao a situação
aí ela falou não tá saindo tudo que é
que site no mundo todo o presidente do
país nenhuma
falou sobre isso o presidente aqui
também e vários atletas do mundo todo
muitas pessoas falando no assunto e aí
eu fiquei preocupado porque eu sou um
cara que não gosto muito da questão de
mídia de nem sempre gostei de ser
valorizado somente pelo meu trabalho
para aquilo que o que eu conquistei né
não
não gosta questão de e começou nessa
está isso eu defino água pra pra falar
com o assessor de imprensa que estava
acontecendo e quando eu cheguei lá tinha
muita gente na recepção prensa de todo
lugar que estava ali cobrindo o jogo e
eu subi rápido ele foi o meu quarto é o
pessoal quer falar contigo
não tem nada pra falar não aí é falta
dormindo eu vou dormir fala com veto a
qualquer coisa e quando acordei no dia
pegamos o vôo cheguei no brasil a coisa
maior ainda maior e clama stop eu não
não queria ver meu nome
girando assim tanto lógico que não fui
eu que procurei aquilo que eu estou
simplesmente andar uma resposta do de
quem não estava preparado com o assunto
mas foi uma resposta que vem do meu
coração é o que imagino que todo que
todo o combate qualquer guerra qualquer
coisa ela tem que ser única solução pra
mim é no amor então foi correspondida
ele que trocaria todos todos meus
títulos pela igualdade foi que me vem na
cabeça aproveitando o gancho ea coisa
começou se fala cada vez mais e até aqui
tocou meu telefone e quem me ligou foi
latina horário emanuel que são
representantes da cufa central única de
favelas onde já fez alguns projetos
juntos de futebol nas comunidades estão
já éramos parceiro em outras atividades
e falou sobre a gente até porque a coisa
está muito grande de criar uma campanha
o projeto alguma coisa que começamos a
falar sobre nomes sobre como poderia ser
feito e lembra que vários nomes que foi
citada lei tinha o nome que era chutando
o racismo porque não está falando sobre
estudar tudo a copa enfim
e aí chegamos à conclusão eu tenho uma
sugestão de nome que eu achava que não
deveria ser chutando o preconceito e
imediatamente eles concordaram que
também tinha essa ideia de que nós
devemos falar não somente do racismo é
de todo o preconceito até porque eu
acredito que quando eu tô né palestrando
que falando sobre o preconceito eu não
preciso falar aqui que o que eu sofri ou
que venha a sofrer gol é pela cor da
pele ou pelo o cabelo enfim assim como
acredito também que quando tem um
deficiente um cadeirante ou obesos
falando aqui não precisa falar aqui que
o que ele venha sofreu sofreu é é do
problema dele a gente nós somos pelo
pelos olhos a gente vê muita coisa
imaginamos e todos nós temos um
pouquinho de preconceito nosso coração
tanto negro branco enfim isso nós temos
isso e e eu tento passar aqui nós
primeiro aceitamos isso que nós temos e
tentamos evoluir melhorar e e aí foi
criado o projeto citando o preconceito
um projeto que é a primeira ação foi no
shopping total antes fez uma atividade
muito legal muita gente participou gente
influente tanto no futebol como na na
mídia e isso acabou correndo o brasil
todo de 16 parece no ano só em 2014
não fiz mais porque estava jogando eu
não tinha tempo e muitas dessas palestra
no modelo de perguntas e respostas e se
eu queria muito que cada vez que
palestrava as pessoas sempre nas
perguntas tinham as perguntas repetidas
assim que era de como que eu como eu
superei isso como eu tive essa
tranquilidade pra pra superar ou para
viver isso e ter calma porque isso não
foi a primeira vez que aconteceu com o
atleta e isso já aconteceu muito tempo
somente na europa acontece direto
e na maioria das vezes o atleta até com
direito ou não mas cada um reage de uma
maneira muito e saiu de campo muito
jogar a camisa muitos reagiram até
xingando o torcedor né eu acredito cada
um reage de uma maneira ea maneira que
eu reagir foi essa só dei uma frase bem
curta mas acho que foi esse o que
significa que se diferenciou o que
impactou então se perguntavam muito isso
como que que eu como eu como pessoa
tinha reagido assim eu não poderia falar
como eu reagia assim sem falar como o
como foi a minha vida né porque a rede
não não faz nada que nós não estamos
preparados e eu nem a preparação a minha
base né
eu sempre falo que eu tinha uma base
muito boa e eu vou explicar para vocês a
minha base familiar que foi muito boa
é uma base onde eu fui criado só pela
minha mãe praticamente com sete anos meu
pai a abandonou e ficou eua uma irmã
mais velha uma base onde a minha mãe
sair às 7 horas da manhã e voltava a
trabalhar e voltava do trabalho a 6
lembro nec é uma das coisas que eu tenho
a memória muito boa memória muito isso
que a minha mãe quando chegava à sexta
sábado e domingo
somente este sábado ela como ela
trabalhava no clube nesse clube tinha a
festa baile
ela fazia uma hora extra e era onde
envia alguma coisa diferente né então eu
lembro que eu chegava do futebol onde eu
gostava de jogar seis horas em casa
minha mãe falava filho não faz barulho
que a mãe vai ter que sair às 10 de novo
para trabalhar então nós três horinhas
que ela tinha porta pra dormir pra
voltar a trabalhar porque ela trabalhava
a madrugada toda
então é isso é a base que eu tenho a
memória que eu tenho de de infância uma
memória de trabalho que chegava em casa
minha mãe tinha acabado de chegar do
trabalho e já estava descansando para
trabalhar de novo eu acordava de manhã
ela chegava 7 8 horas da manhã
e trazendo alguma coisa diferente assim
talvez uma coisa pra comer que eu não
via a semana inteira então eu na minha
cabeça imaginava que o trabalho a
honestidade a disciplina de horário que
ela tinha tanto de dormir pra sair já
que isso trazia coisa boa porque
acordava de manhã e ficava na janela
esperando e vinha cheia de sacolas é
correndo para pegar então isso em
crescendo quis que o imaginado que
trabalhar e cumprir os horários
era coisa muito boa porque quando eu
pedia um tênis uma coisa ela falava
semana vou trabalhar mais tempo então
vou conseguir comprar o tênis então é a
base que eu tive foi de trabalho da
necessidade de cumprir horários enfim
isso foi uma das coisas que eu fui
levando na minha carreira desde o tempo
que quando cheguei no grêmio com 15 anos
há sempre falo que eu fui educado dentro
do esporte nem por isso o incentivo
muito todas as escolas que têm o esporte
junto à música enfim qualquer coisa aqui
que disciplina que mantém horários enfim
eu eu acabei levando isso a minha vida
inteira então sempre escondido as
pessoas que o o horário trabalho foi a
minha base porque os porque eu falo isso
porque eu vejo muita gente se colocando
e às vezes até usando isso como desculpa
que não teve base que foi criar só pela
mãe ou só pelo pai e eu não ver o que
isso não que foi o que fez a falta pra
ele eu não vejo isso a minha bahia eu
posso dizer que eu tive muita base e fui
criado só pela minha mãe e minha mãe
praticamente trabalhando o dia inteiro
então na verdade como foi falado aqui a
gente escolhe nosso destino a gente
escolhe o que é quente o que a gente
quer pegar de de exemplo você pode muito
eu podia muito bem usar isso como
desculpa não fui criado só pela minha
mãe não vi ela praticamente só vi a
noite e podia usar isso como desculpa e
me tornar mais uma pessoa com um sem
objetivos sem foco sem profissão
e as muitas pessoas pode falar mas teve
sorte eu falei eu tive muita sorte mesmo
e toda vez que a sorte encontrou amy
encontrou trabalhando isso foi a grande
sorte que eu tive sorte quando chegou
até a mim nunca estava sem fazer nada
estava sempre trabalhando esperando ela
essa é a sorte que eu tenho na minha
vida de ter tido um exemplo da minha mãe
um exemplo de de muita luta de muito
trabalho e queria falar pra vocês que me
orgulha muito né é dever num sábado de
manhã
pessoas de diferentes idades e
profissões enfim preocupada com todos os
assuntos que não sei falar daqui
isso mostra que nós temos condições de
dizer um país melhor de ser uma pessoa
melhor
isso me estimula porque num sábado de
manhã e com folga podendo fazer tanta
coisa está aqui para escutar histórias
diferentes vida diferente isso mostra
que nós temos pessoas dedicadas às
pessoas que podem mudar o mundo como foi
falado aqui canal mudando o seu agente
vai chegar a um objetivo maior cada um
tentando mudar o seu mundo e isso foi
uma das coisas que me levou a que me
estimulou a a cada dia mais um não me
tornar simplesmente 11 jogador me tornar
uma pessoa porque eu sempre pensei que é
o dia que eu parar de jogar futebol e
tem que dar conta de o paulo césar como
pessoa
mesmo com os erros com acerto porque nós
somos humanos tem muito isso mas
procurar sempre ter uma vida que ela
pudesse seguir pós o futebol com
respeito como homem porque eu acredito
quando a gente tem um talento faz algo
muitas vezes as pessoas atuam pelo
talento que a gente tem mas cometia um
homem e tem uma disciplina as pessoas o
saturno e nos respeitam na verdade nós
gostam da gente pelo pelo nosso caráter
isso como uma coisa que eu aprendi e
queria passar para vocês que através do
trabalho através da entidade a gente
consegue alcançar nossos objetivos e
tenho aprendido nos últimos nos últimos
anos né a grande adesão de malandragem
de século é quando fala é só falar a
malandragem muitas pessoas se assustam
né eu também não gosto dessa palavra
malandragem mas eu tenho eu tenho
aprendido isso tem vivido isso na minha
vida na minha nos últimos anos de
carreira principalmente por trabalhar
trabalhar fora do futebol também entanto
parte social como também em outras áreas
particulares que a grande humanidade do
século é honestidade
isso é uma coisa que parece muito
simples né
mas a honestidade hoje é a grande
vantagem do século tanto no business
tanto no dia a dia tanto com as pessoas
está muito difícil de ter isso hoje todo
mundo já pensa na sua vantagem é que vai
ganhar o que eu voltei para estar lá
então tá muito difícil ver isso eu tenho
de vida e isso nos últimos anos de
carreira e isso tem me dado
é uma alegria muito grande e eu vou ou
não estava combinado mas eu vou
confidenciar pra vocês aqui que eu vou
parar de jogar agora em abril
neto dando em primeira mão aí senti isso
de falar aqui e vou parar com uma honra
muito grande
obrigado obrigado e talvez a que todo o
jogador e todo atleta sonha anunciar
isso num estádio cheio como vive a vida
inteira mas pra mim é um orgulho maior
podia estar aliciando isso numa sala
onde tanto tem tanta gente formada tanta
gente capacitada meu sonho disse como eu
comecei a me entender como como gente
era poder um dia tá em cima do do palco
falando com as pessoas que
verdadeiramente são livros pra mim o
verdadeiro ídolo léo é um professor é um
médico àqueles que educam naqueles que
foram pra mim esse é o verdadeiro ídolo
e teve que salvar a vida
aquele que cuida de vidas então poderia
estar fazendo isso no estádio lotado mas
eu me orgulho muito de estar podendo
fazer isso não sei quantas pessoas têm
aqui mas eu sei que as pessoas estão
aqui são pessoas que influenciam as
vidas de verdade
muito obrigado foi dessa maneira que eu
que eu chutei toda dificuldade na minha
vida eu quero saber como vocês vão
chutar cara dificuldade na vida de vocês